imágenes impresionantes se viven en la
estación londinense de saint pancras
miles de pasajeros forman filas a la
espera de tomar un bus de eurostar
debido a la entrada en vigor de las
restricciones a los viajes entre francia
y reino unido- a pesar del apoyo de las
fuerzas armadas en la vacunación reino
unido- alcanza todos los días nuevos
récords de contagios más de 93 mil casos
el viernes en alemania las cifras
también son preocupantes mientras la
vacunación se abre para los niños las
autoridades esperan que las próximas
semanas sean extremadamente difíciles
nos tenemos que preparar para un desafío
que no hemos tenido que enfrentar desde
el comienzo de la pandemia la agitación
que se expande por europa tiene
consecuencias muy concretas en la
frontera entre francia e italia -roma
impone test pcr a cualquier persona
incluso vacunada que quiera entrar en el
país en 20.000 ya estos franceses
aceptan las medidas si todo el mundo
hace esto tal vez salgamos adelante los
comerciantes italianos en cambio tienen
más dificultades las nuevas
restricciones han afectado sus negocios
una situación que se repite desde el sur
hasta el norte de europa
hace una semana dinamarca ha tomado las
primeras medidas alentando el
teletrabajo sin mucho éxito pues los
casos se duplicaron en sólo ocho días el
viernes el gobierno anunció nuevas
restricciones a los teatros los cines
los parques de diversiones los
zoológicos los salones de eventos y
todos los lugares donde se reúne mucha
gente deberán cerrar
antes todo anímense a summers disquera
locos en los días por venir la lista de
países europeos que opten por nuevas
restricciones sanitarias podría
alargarse